ce 64e de finale pourrait être le match
de leur vie
depuis le tirage au sort mi décembre le
choc face à l'aj auxerre est dans toutes
les têtes
joueurs entraîneurs de le lui en cours
ont du mal à rester en place
mais pas question de changer les
habitudes à l'entraînement ce soir là au
programme ateliers de vivacité et
conservation de balle comme tous les
mardis on sait qu'on fait du foncier de
mardi avec un petit peu de jeux de
ballons demain soit en fait un petit
match amical et jeudi comme d'habitude
ça sera plus de jeux de ballons avec les
gardiens et tout ça mais on change
vraiment pas plus que ça à l'habitude de
les en vraiment auxerre n'est autre que
le champion de france en titre de la
catégorie tout simplement ce qui se fait
de mieux dans l'hexagone
mais ce palmarès n'impressionne pas les
jeunes saint quentinois ils feront tout
pour vaincre l'ogre bourguignon imiter
epinal en coupe de france tombeur de
l'olympique lyonnais il ya quelques
jours ces clubs là c'est bobo foutant
hadjer puisque c'est rare que des clubs
comme ça ils arrivent à s'imposer face à
des gros clubs mais c'était à une chose
créer la surprise pour moi ouais ils ont
des jambes et deux bras comme nous voilà
on est plus motivé que jamais alors
carrément la cgppa c'est comme un rêve
pour nous tous on est heureux mais si on
peut aller plus loin royal et on va tout
faire pour
lors des quatre premiers tours
l'entraîneur n'avait pas anticipé la
séance de tirs au but
un moment crucial où jordan doussain
gardien de but de le sg sera plus que
jamais le dernier rempart c'est un
exercice que j'aime bien mais si on
pouvait ne pas y arriver ça serait mieux
mais si elle est penalty aura les
penaltys en phr avec il ya des
techniques mais bon souvent c'est
l'instinct pour la plupart les jeunes
guyancourt toi jouent ensemble depuis
cinq voire six saisons plus que onze
joueurs c'est une bande de copains qui
voudra à tout prix continuer l aventure
le staff a transmis des messages sur le
mur du vestiaire
à quelques minutes du coup d'envoi
chacun se prépare à sa manière c'est
alors que le gardien de but jordan
doussain prend la parole c'est des
joueurs comme nous il ya encore ça se
trouve ils sont alors rentrés pour un
mi-temps en pas de butin on vient à 1,00
minimum les joueurs d'olivier jean vrai
se réalise une bonne entame de match
poussé par des supporters chauffés à
blanc le staff ça continue on avait
choisi de jouer avec un bloc défensif
très bas pour contrer la vitesse de
course des attaquants auxerrois
malgré ce rideau défensif les yvelinois
pris par l'enjeu encaisse un premier but
sur corner sur cette déviation au
premier poteau
dans ce premier acte malgré la
possession de balle les rouge et noir ne
collectionne pas les occasions de but
excepté sur coups de pied arrêtés et les
bourguignons creuse l'écart juste avant
la mi temps sur cette superbe ouverture
direction les vestiaires pendant ce
temps là les supporters commencent à
être fataliste aux photographies je
crois qu'ils en aient tant au niveau
entre auxerre puis en cours mais bon
moment ils font ils font ce qu'ils
peuvent le pigeonneau en seconde période
les joueurs d'olivier jean jaurès ne
lâche rien mais la supériorité auxerrois
se fait sentir au fil des minutes sur
cette ouverture côté droit jordan
doussain attrape la jambe de l'attaquant
auxerrois
le penalty est transformé le sort du
match scellé dans les dernières minutes
jordan doussain encaissera un quatrième
but plutôt anecdotique le rêve passe les
auxerrois était trop fort et se sont
logiquement imposés mais la fierté du
parcours effectué domine malgré la
défaite je pense qu'on n'a pas développé
le foot on développe de l'habitude
maintenant bon ton quand même contrat
sans de formation c'est des joueurs qui
courent du football qu'on du ballon où
on n'a pas à rougir un 4 0
bon voila quand on perd mais on n'a
vraiment pas à rougir de notre
performance est en tout cas je suis ici
vraiment majeur ce qu'ils nous ont fait
un parcours exceptionnel
on peut le dire et donc voilà je suis
vraiment fier fier pour eux fier pour le
club
enfin ça a été difficile on a vu l'écart
qui avait mais bon on s'est battu
jusqu'à la fin et puis on n'a pas de na
pas avoir de regrets en a pas on peut
relever la tête ce qu'on a fait un bon
match quoi grégory chassaing et ses
copains vont devoir oublier cette
élimination et se replonger très vite
dans leur quotidien le championnat de
première division de district